Speaker 1: OK, so over the weekend, there
was a Fox News Channel interview, the interviewer
was Laura Ingram.
The interviewee was the former President Donald
Trump.
This is a very relevant interview for the
next two election cycles now that it's clear
they would try the coup again if they could.
Now that it's clear Donald Trump is planning
to be involved in 2022 and quite plausibly
in 2024.
Now that we know that the coup had a power
point, I mean, all of this stuff.
This must be taken really, really seriously.
So we're going to go through a number of different
lies told by Trump, but we're going to really
build to the commentary about what may be
coming in the future for the United States.
Speaker 2: So first, just to
Speaker 1: reintroduce us to the uncontrollable
Speaker 2: lying Donald Trump
Speaker 1: again makes very
Speaker 2: deceptive and untrue
Speaker 1: claims about gas
Speaker 2: prices.
Speaker 1: Now why the gas price issue is
even an issue.
Speaker 2: Remember, there's a lot of people
who play the political football
Speaker 1: of blaming or praising presidents
for high or low gas prices, depending on what
is convenient.
Based on your Partizan affiliation, I don't
play that game.
Presidents have almost nothing to do with
gas prices, but Trump plays the game, he says
when he left office.
Gas was at a dollar 87, and now it's at seven
77 in California.
Those numbers sound weird.
They should.
And let's look at the clip first.
Speaker 6: You look at gas prices.
The gasoline was at one point eighty seven
cents a gallon, and now in California, it's
over $7 777 to be exact, and it's going to
be catching up with a lot of other parts of
the country.
So.
Speaker 2: OK, so
Speaker 1: it's all either
Speaker 2: a lie or deceptive.
Speaker 1: When Trump left office,
Speaker 2: gas was a dollar
Speaker 1: eighty seven, he says that's not
true.
When Trump left office, gas was 242.
So is it higher today?
Yes.
But was it a dollar?
Eighty seven?
No.
When Trump left office, it was 30 percent
higher at 2:42.
Trump says gas is now 777 in California.
And what's dishonest about that?
Well, even if it were true that gas prices
are 777 in California.
Comparing California to the national number
doesn't make sense.
The official national gas price is now 349.
Speaker 2: So you don't compare
Speaker 1: 187
Speaker 2: or the real
Speaker 1: number to
Speaker 2: 42.
A year ago,
Speaker 1: or when you left office to a specific
gas station in California, that doesn't make
sense.
You compare it to the official number in the
U.S., and that is now 349.
It's 349 instead of 242.
Is gas more now than
Speaker 2: when Trump left?
Speaker 1: Yes, it is dramatically.
It's a dramatically smaller gap than what
Trump claimed.
Speaker 2: And remember, presidents
Speaker 1: don't control gas prices.
Now lastly, even the California number is
Hawaii California gas right now.
The national, the official, the official state
number is 460, not 777.
Is there some gas station in California
Speaker 2: where super
Speaker 1: premium maybe was 777?
Speaker 2: Maybe.
I don't know.
Speaker 1: But that's not how you look at.
No.
Speaker 2: So it's all lies and he keeps telling
them.
Speaker 1: Trump then says, and this is totally
unintelligible.
He's like his brain is glitching.
It's like mayonnaise or vegan.
Ms. Trump claims Democrats are going to try
to use the debt ceiling for the Supreme Court
and other stuff.
Speaker 2: I don't even know what he's saying.
Take a listen
Speaker 6: to absolutely kill that.
Now they're going to use it for the Supreme
Court.
And even worse than that, they could have
used it for the so-called voting rights, which
is a disaster for our country.
And certainly it's a disaster for the Republican
Party.
Speaker 1: I don't think that's going to pass.
But Arizona, just off the wall, off the wall,
no idea what mechanisms he is even referring
to.
Trump was then asked about invoking or attempting
to invoke executive privilege, even though
he's no longer president over documents related
to the Jan. six Trump riots.
And he again says there was no insurrection
on January six.
The insurrection was Election Day,
Speaker 2: November of 2020.
Speaker 1: This is his new talking point,
and I'll explain it in about and hear about
the executive privilege and Biden's decision
to release those documents.
Your reaction tonight?
Speaker 6: Well, we're going to have to see
what happens if you look at the protests,
there was a protest.
The insurrection took place on November 3rd,
which was Election Day.
This was a protest and a lot of innocent people
are being hurt.
A lot of innocent people are being injured.
I would say the panel of judges that we're
talking about didn't exactly like Trump.
And if you look at the appointments, you can
figure that one out for yourself.
But this was a absolute protest and people
are being treated very, very unfairly.
There were.
Rights are being taken away from them, and
the other side is not, you take a look at
what's going on with BLM and Antifa.
What they did in Portland and Minneapolis
and Seattle, and nothing happens.
But what happened, by the way, people were
killed.
Nobody was killed here other than Ashley Babbitt,
who was shot violently by a man that should
not have ever been allowed to pull that trigger.
So this granny is separate, but OK.
Speaker 1: So, so the the talk the story
Speaker 2: is, Trump
Speaker 1: says.
What happened on
Speaker 2: January six was not a
Speaker 1: coup.
It was not an insurrection, and my supporters
weren't violent.
It was BLM and antifa if anyone was violent,
but otherwise it was a peaceful protest.
The real insurrection was when they stole
Speaker 2: it from me, him
Speaker 1: in November of
Speaker 2: 2020.
And he also
Speaker 1: continues to
Speaker 2: insist that all of
Speaker 1: these hundreds of
Speaker 2: defendants, the rioters were actually
Speaker 1: innocent and now are being treated
poorly.
It's wild.
I mean, these and now is where it starts to
get
Speaker 2: dangerous because people believe
this stuff
Speaker 1: and they're going to try it again
in 2024 with Trump or with someone else.
Trump then attacked attacks the make up of
the January 6th committee and says they aren't
real Republicans.
It's only Kinzinger and Cheney.
But why is that?
Well, let's look at the clip, and then I'll
explain.
Speaker 6: We have Lindsey, Liz Cheney and
Kinzinger.
Two people that should not be on that committee.
We don't have Republicans on the, I call it,
the select committee of Democrat partizans.
It's ridiculous what's going on with it.
And he has done a terrible job.
You have the, I call it, the infrastructure
bill because it's not infrastructure.
Speaker 1: So Trump says they don't have real
Republicans.
They only have people
Speaker 2: like Adam
Speaker 1: Kinzinger and Liz Cheney.
Speaker 2: Well, that's because other Republicans
abandoned
Speaker 1: the initial plan for the committee
and said, we're not going to participate,
which made Nancy Pelosi have to go out and
find Republicans willing to be on it.
Does it mean
Speaker 2: we wouldn't prefer a different
make
Speaker 1: up of the.
No, of course not.
But come on, it's another deceptive claim.
So here's what's very clearly going on.
Trump is dramatically accelerating the pace
of his media interviews over the last two
weeks.
Why the 2022 midterms are about to start is
ramping up for 2022.
He wants to be the kingmaker.
He wants people donating to him so that through
his PAC, he can support candidates.
Speaker 2: He is definitely going to be involved
in campaigns in 2022.
Speaker 1: And then.
This is all part of the buildup
Speaker 2: to try again
Speaker 1: with any means
Speaker 2: necessary, any means they
Speaker 1: can get away with in 2024.
There is no doubt now whether the candidate
will be Trump.
That's a different question.
We don't know the answer to that yet.
Over the last 10 days, more and more people
saying it's going to be Trump.
I think his health may be the biggest limiting
factor.
We just don't know yet.
Speaker 2: But this is building.
Speaker 1: He's doing interviews more and
more
Speaker 2: frequently to sell the book, sure,
Speaker 1: but also because we are about to
get very much in with what might be some of
the most anticipated.
I mean, it sounds cliche, but in a way what
is going to happen?
Speaker 2: We all Democrats
Speaker 1: lose everything other than the
White House in November
Speaker 2: of twenty two or
Speaker 1: not, and Trump wants
to
Speaker 2: be very much involved.